bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat à suivre ce matin l'audition
d'Arnaud monondtebourg le ministre du
redressement productif a été entendu
hier par les sénateurs de la commission
des affaires économiques présidé par le
sénateur socialiste daniel Raoul retour
donc à cette audition qui a eu lieu hier
après-midi au Sénat monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord permettez-moi de me régir
d'avoir pu vous convier cette réunion
c'est une première devant la
commission des affaires économiques en
tous les cas
elle permet sans doute aux élus de
terrain aussi que nous sommes de
manifester leur intérêt et leur capacité
de mobilisation face l'urgence sociale
qu'on vient d'évoquer d'ailleurs dans un
autre cadre avec le rapport de la Cour
des comptes sur la politique de la ville
et une urgence économique vous sa au
combien d'actualité tout le monde peut
le mesurer il compris dans la presse ce
matin et bien sûr la politique
industrielle quand on tombe à 12 % du
PIB au niveau de la de l'industrie on
doit se poser les questions je sais bien
qu'il y a un débat à l'infini sur
l'externalisation de certains services
et que le 12 % représente peut-être plus
mais en tous les cas en dessous de 20%
on considère qu'il y a un vrai problème
concernant la survie d'une politique
industrielle dans un pays et
que à part se transformer en gardien de
musée c'est vrai qu'on est déjà dans un
musée ici nous serions peut-être pas des
paysés il y a quand même un problème
concernant à la fois le développement
économique et social de notre pays bien
entendu cette urgence se manifeste de la
façon la plus visible et immédiate dans
certains
secteurs monsieur le ministre comme vous
l'avez indiqué le 13
juillet dernier au Sénat la question
tout entiè la nation tout entière devra
se rassembler autour de son industrie en
particulier automobile qui est le sujet
d'actualité le plus prignant mais il y
en a d'Es que j'évoquerai tout à l'heure
j'ajoute après que nous ayons entendu le
président de France tééecom orange la
semaine dernière qu'il nous faut être
attentif à l'équilibre économique du
secteur aussi des télé mais ça pourrait
être vrai pour d'autres secteurs étant
donné les enjeux en terme de valeur
ajoutée d'innovation d'emploi et
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
autrement dit jusqu'à où on doit mettre
le curseur entre le pouvoir du
consommateur ou le pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur et les effets collatéraux
sur les emplois et je j'évoque
évidemment la 4e licence et cetera et la
perturbation que ceci a créé dans le
secteur économique des
télécommunications
ces deux secteurs feront l'objet
d'annonce officielle sans doute demain
pour l'automobile et pour les
télécommunications en conseil des
ministres si mes informations sont
justes
d'échange
avec Madame fleur pèlerin demain matin
devant notre commission c'est pourquoi
je propose aujourd'hui de donner à nos
échanges une tonalité plus générale
j'appelle mes collègu sénatrices et
sénateur à s'fforcer dans la mesure du
possible de maintenir ce cap lorsqu'il
poser des questions quand je dis ce cap
c'est aussi sur la durée si possible
nous avons fait une expérience la
semaine dernière de donner 2 minutes à
chacun des intervenants je sais que nous
sommes limités également qu'à 18h30 nous
recevrons monsieur Stéphane Lefol
accompagné de Guillaume Garot et donc
j'aimerais bien dans vos prises de
parole que vous respectiez à peu près ce
challenge sur vos questions et qu'il
n'est pas pour l'heure euh ce n'est pas
l'objet
de faire une
déclaration de politique de chacun
d'entre vous il s'agit d'abord
d'auditionner le ministre et de lui
poser des questions que le cadre soit
bien clair bon courage monsieur le
ministre faites confiance à la
créativité dans ce domaine donc
j'introduirai en fait notre sujet par
trois brèves remarques la
réindustrialisation cher à notre
collègue
Bourquin que j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler à ses côtés dans cette
mission sur la industrialisation mais
une cette place en fait est centrale
sans doute par rapport au redressement
productif qui est votre mission de la
donnée par le Premier ministre et
évidemment par le Président de la
République la réindustrialisation c'est
d'abord je pense analyse qu'on avait
fait une rupture non seulement avec la
priorités excessives qui avait été
accordé depuis 20 ans au secteur
tertiaire mais aussi avec son en
corollaire la focalisation sur la baisse
du coût du travail et peut-être
d'ailleurs sur la durée mais on aura
l'occasion de réévoquer en particulier
dans les comparaisons par rapport à
l'Allemagne je vous rappelle que
l'Allemagne est un État fédéral que
j'aimerais bien qu'on compare les choses
compara c'est-à-dire les trois landur du
sud et de l'ouest et qu'on compare ceci
à nos chiffres concernant les coûts de
production et on aurait peut-être
quelques surprises je regarde je regarde
Martiel Bourquin puisqueon on fait une
mission commune
à à Stuttgart et on avait été surpris
des résultats contrairement à ce qu'on
entendait évidemment dans l'exagon c'est
ensuite une
stratégie
territorialisée de ce point de vue nous
attendons bien entendu des retombées
positives de la nomination des 22
commissaires que vous avez annoncé au
redressement productif c'est-à-dire un
par région placé directement auprès des
préfets des régions son doute que vous
nous expliquerez le rôle que vous att
que vous entendez donner à ces
commissaires mais je vous surprendrez
pas en saisissant ici l'occasion de
rappeler une nécessité tout aussi vitale
c'est d'associer les élus du terrain au
politique économique et on le sait bien
en tous les cas que entre la région et
les interc c'est là que se joue le
développement économique des
territoires
nous en reparlerons dans l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation non non mais j'entends
bien les
PCG bon en évoquant monsieur le ministre
la notion de colbertisme participatif
j'ai bien lu la
presse vous avez su exprimer à
volontarisme que nous Presque Oui c'est
vrai en tous les cas exprimer un
volontarisme que nous soutenons dans son
principe en même même temps comment
pourrions-nous ne pas rappeler la valeur
irremplaçable de la contribution des
élus locaux au développement économique
quel que soit leur collectivité ça vous
ira mieux mes chers collègues et tout
spécialement au Sénat qui est censé les
représenter enfin la réindustrialisation
a besoin d'outils efficaces tout en
mentionnant l'importance au plan humain
de ce qu'on appelle la sécurité sociale
professionnelle qui inclut la formation
je me contentai ici d'insister sur les
soutiens financiers
sans lequel rien n'est possible là
encore en ce qui concerne les
subventions d'investissement les
collectivités territoriales apportent
une contribution majeure sans doute
pourrez-vous faire le point des
nouvelles orientations données à la
mécanique parfois jugé complexe
d'ailleurs géré par le Commissariat
général à
l'investissement qui je le rappelle doit
allouer au secteur d'avenir les 9
milliards d'euros restants à ventilés du
grand emprunt sur les 35 prévu lancé en
janvier 2010 de façon plus globale
pouvez-vous nous préciser modalité selon
laquelle la BPI enfin la banque public
d'investissement pourra déployer un
réseau de distribution unique de
l'ensemble des outils publics de
financement et prégaranti les fonds
propres les subventions et les projets à
l'exportation nous avons eu l'occasion
avec deux ou trois collègues d'en parler
au FSI la semaine dernière et entre le
FSI ozo et cette banque publique
d'investissement je souhaiterais voir
les articulations et en tous les cas
trouver des synergies sinon de la
cohérence queles seront les conséquences
de ce schéma sur les activités le statut
de la Caisse des Dépôts CDC sa filiale
CDC entreprise dans les 77 fonds
régionaux gèent en même temps plus de 12
milliards
d'euros donc c'est l'ensemble de ces
outils FSI ozo CDC entreprise BPI comme
je souhaite avoir une vision en tous les
cas stratégique de l'articulation de ces
outils enfin vous serez pas étonné qu'il
y a un sujet qui passionne à la fois je
sais pas s'il est là Marc Denis et
moi-même sur l'utilisation du CIR du
fameux cire et je suis pas tout à fait
je le dis posément tout à fait en phase
avec certaines propositions qui ont été
faites lors d'un rapport d'un collègue
de la commission des finances ça fait 3
ans que nous nous oui je sais que nous
nous battons pour obtenir un taux
supérieur pour les PMI innovante pour le
statut des Ji et ça me semblerait bien
plus important que de continuer à
alimenter la red mais je le dis
calmement des grands groupes qui en plus
font de l'optimisation alors je sais
bien que mon cher collègue vous avez
minimiser cet aspect là dans votre
rapport euh y compris je peux vous
suivre sur les banques sur les holdings
financières mais je considère qu'à
enveloppe constante je ne rêve pas le
père de Noël je suis pas sûr qu'il passe
cette année et donc mieux utiliser le
CIR pour favoriser l'innovation mais
qu'elle soit industrielle ou managéiale
enfin l'innovation on peut la décliner
sur différents aspects et la créativité
c'est bien dans les PME les Ji que ça se
fait plus que d'ailleurs que dans les
grands groupes je le dis non non mais on
y reviendra d'accord la dernière
question monsieur le ministre c'est dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle
j'avais bien entendu parler d'un projet
de loi de reprise pour en tous les cas
les entreprises économiquement viable et
en parti c'est d'actualité avec vous
savez bien
euh comment
oui le site de comment pettropl de
comment arcer l'ormital j'en pase c'est
des meilleurs qu' y en a plusieurs dans
dans votre portefeuille si je dire je je
peux m'exprimer ainsi euh c'est vrai
pour le thé éléphant enfin bon on pourra
on pourrait continuer à décliner les
choses autrement dit quand est-ce que ce
projet de loi sera dans les tuyaux et
mis à notre soumis à notre sagesse au
Parlement j'en ai fini Monsieur Roland
corau et je je laisse donc la parole à
Monsieur le Ministre et je vous laisse
oui mais non mais vous vous êtes pas
limité mais mes collègues le seront
alors vous avez seul la parole monsieur
le ministre j'ai été trop long je
sais bien monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de votre invitation à
débattre l'ancien parlementaire je suis
qui été qui pas député pendant 15 ans
est très attaché à la discussion
parlementaire à l'échange de points de
vue et en dehors de la qualité éminente
de membr de la haute chambre vous êtes
aussi les
titulaires dans la Constitution
dépositaire en quelque sorte de
l'intérêt des collectivités locales donc
des territoires il est évident que dans
la mobilisation nationale en faveur du
redressement notre
industrie notre économie plus largement
les territoires sont appelés à jouer un
rôle important c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je crois utile que sans
laisser passer l'été nous ayons eu ce ce
cet échange euh j'attache un grand soin
non seulement au dialogue entre les deux
pouvoir le Parlement et le gouvernement
mais aussi
à ce qu'on
appelle les interventions sur les
entreprise le regard qu'un élu porte sur
une entreprise est toujours pour nous
instructif donc ne considérz pas que
vous gênez le ministre en lui demandant
des informations ou des comptes autant
que nous le pouvons évidemment nous
avons besoin de votre connaissance du
terrain de la même manière que les
fonctionnaires au premier rang les les
préfets les commissaires que nous avons
nommés qui sont chargés je vous le dirai
tout à
l'heure de faire face quand même à la
l'affectation de la chaîes économique
hein dans toutes ces
composantes sont à la disposition des
pour tâcher de mobiliser tout le monde
sur les territoires au service de la des
sauvetages dès lors que nous pouvons euh
nous pouvons le faire qu'est-ce que le
redressement productif c'est d'abord
l'inspiration directe euh du président
de ce grand président des États-Unis qui
était Franklin Roosevelt après la Grande
Dépression de 1929 qui avait employé
l'expression de redressement industriel
nationale et lorsque le président de la
République m'a fait la proposition
d'être le ministre que j'ai accepté
d'être il m'a proposé d'être le ministre
du redressement productif je dis mais
pourquoi pas industriel et je lui ai
répondu parce que c'est beaucoup
plus il m'a répondu parce que il faut
aller plus largement que l'industrie la
question des services est aussi dedans
la question de l'agriculture est aussi
concernée toute la chaîne économique
aujourd'hui après 10 années finalement
de perte dans le PIB des source de
productive industrielle nous sommes à
750000 emplois industriels
perdus une balance commerciale à - 70
milliards ça veut dire que nous
importons de plus en plus ce que nous
consommons et produisons de moins en
moins nous-mêmes ce que ce dont nous
avons besoin donc c'est le signe quand
même d'une maladie de notre économie et
la question du redressement notre
appareil productif c'est mettre en face
de la demande ce dont nous avons besoin
et d'avoir les appareils industriels
productifs pour le faire évidemment dans
un univers ouvert où la question de la
compétition notre place dans la
mondialisation notre stratégie par par
rapport à la mondialisation est
évidemment posée l'esprit de ce
renouveau productif industriel
évidemment va demander des efforts à
chacun je je dois vous dire que
d'ailleurs le le la manière dont avec le
Premier ministre nous
lorsqu'un sinistre survient ou des
difficultés apparaissent nous engageons
le dialogue avec l'ensemble des
partenaires de l'entreprise nous
veillons à ce qu'il y ait un équilibre
des responsabilités nous en appelons à
la responsabilité industrielle des
actionnaires et des financiers qu'il soi
banquier ou qu'il soi les fonds de
pension ou les financiers qui se sont
rendus propriétaires de l'entreprise
nous en appelons à la responsabilité
sociale des entreprises car les êtres
humains au travail les salariés ne
peuvent pas être la permanente variable
d'ajustement des difficultés des
entreprises et de ce point de vue-là les
erreurs de gestion les problèmes
d'actionnariat parfois les caprices même
ou les exigences excessives de
l'actionnariat sont doivent être placés
dans le cœur de la discussion et de
l'équilibre et du compromis et nous en
appelons à la responsabilité également
économique des syndicat car les luttes
sociales les rapports de force doivent
toujours avoir une relation avec la
réalité économique de manière à ce que
nous ne perdions pas des outils
industriels mais que nous arrivions à
surmonter ensemble en rapprochant les
points de vue responsabilité
industrielle des actionnaires et des
financiers responsabilité sociale des
entreprises
responsabilité économique des syndicats
nous pouvons nous rassembler autour du
redressement productif c'est dans cet
état d'esprit que j'aborde tous les
dossiers lorsque nous avons une
restructuration nous demandons un effort
à chacun toutes les ressources sont
mises à contribution les salariés ne
sont pas les seuls à faire des
sacrifices et c'est nécessaire lorsqu'il
y a des sacrifices à faire et
inéluctable il faut même les réduire et
veiller à ce que ces sacrifices soient
les moins élevés possibles car l'emploi
est la priorité de ce gouvernement c'est
même j'allais dire la première des
priorités de nos compatriotes ensuite il
y a aussi les efforts que tous les
autres doivent faire les actionnaires
doivent recapitaliser c'est leur
responsabilité les banquiers doivent
reconnaître leurs erreurs s'ils en ont
commis les créanciers doivent faire un
effort les donneurs d'ordre les
partenaires de l'entreprise doivent
veiller à assurer une part de solidarité
c'est l'esprit d'entraide dans lequel
tous les pays qui ont réussi à s'unir
dans leurs différentes composantes ont
pu passer sans encombre la crise les
pays qui ont résisté et qui sont
aujourd'hui concurrent sont des pays où
la puissance publique les grands groupes
les petites entreprises ont réussi à
s'unir donc mon travail c'est de bâtir
ses compromis et l'unité autour euh de
l'objectif du redressement industriel
car derrière c'est la question de la
baisse du chômage qui est à terme posé
et et en tout cas proposé quels sont les
pour aller vite et ne pas encombrer
davantage les débats vous donner
l'esprit dans lequel nous travaillons au
gouvernement quel est l'esprit de ce
plan en quelque sorte de reconquête
industrielle d'abord la question de
notre place dans la mondialisation la
question de la compétitivité euh coût
n'est pas euh un sujet tabou pour nous
nous le regardons en face nous sommes
prêts à mener le débat mais pas avec des
slogans ou des formules choc ou des
accusations euh de toutes sortes
j'entends souvent euh euh dire que le
coût du travail est la cause de nos
difficultés il y a un débat et je dois
vous dire que même s'agissant de
l'automobile euh il y a un débat chez
les prenons l'exemple des constructeurs
il y a un débat chez les constructeurs
Toyota n'a pas la même analyse elle qui
vient de relocaliser des activités sur
le territoire national pour des voitures
à destination du marché américain ne
tient pas le même langage sur la
question du coût du travail les élus du
Nord le savent parfaitement monsieur le
roi le PDG de Toyota Europe le répète
dès qu'il le peut pour eux ce n'est pas
un problème de coût du travail pour une
raison simple c'est que dans le prix de
revient d'une automobile le coût du
travail c'est entre 8 et 15 % donc
diminuer même de 20 % quelque chose qui
ne pèse que 8 % c'est ne pas avoir un
avantage comp comptif sérieux donc je
souvent on nous parle du modèle allemand
mais c'eston que en Allemagne même si
l'Allemagne dans le prix du travail tout
compris une politique de désinflation
compétitive avec modération
salariale diminution de la protection
sociale a eu pour conséquence de
rattraper la France qui avait un
avantage compétitif coût en 10 ans je
veux observer qu'aujourd'hui les
syndicats allemands obtiennent des
hausses de salaires que IG métal dans la
métallurgie à négocier les 32 heures
donc nous savons que pour aborder la
question du coût du travail il faut
regarder la question en face
sérieusement en équilibrant notre
jugement et en évitant le dogmatisme ou
le préjugé parce que nous aurons de
belles surprise et il est possible que
si dans certains secteurs les
constructeurs demandent des baisses du
coût du travail dans d'autres la
question n'est pas posée dans ces termes
donc nous avons fait le choix de poser
la question de cette de cette
problématique mais au regard des autres
pour nous les coûts de production
concernent trois facteurs le prix du
travail le financement de la protection
sociale ce n'est pas un sujet interdit
le Premier ministre sur ma proposition a
confié à Louis Galois l'ancien président
de ADS le soin de mener une mission
d'enquête contradictoire sur ce sujet de
manière à structurer le débat entre les
partenaires sociaux et entre le
gouvernement et le Parlement à la
rentrée au mois d'octobre
deuxè donc nous aurons sur ce sujet le
débat il n'y a pas de débat interdit
vous pourrez présenter vos idées vos
propositions vos diagnostiqus vos
analyses nous les confronterons et nous
arriverons au point de vérité la nation
ne peut pas se permettre ni d'esquiver
de ce débat ni de l'escamoter donc
regardons le problème en face
deuxièmement c'est la question euh du
prix du capital moi je dis toujours si
on regarde le prix du travail il faut
regarder le prix du capital c'est-à-dire
la gourmandise du système financier
l'angloaxonisation de l'économie et est
un de nos problèmes qui d'ailleurs ne
correspond pas à l'ADN de notre modèle
économique le modèle Renant en quelque
sorte
lorsque finalement l'endettement sert de
moyens d'acquisition de l'entreprise le
LBO l'evage
Byout nous avons vu beaucoup de dégâts
sur le territoire lorsque nous voyons le
ROE servir de Bousso pour tous les
investisseurs même prétendument avisé
avec des rentabilités à deux chiffres le
equity quel equity car nous avons vu des
entreprises fermer parce que elles
n'avaient pas de rentabilité à deux
chiffres sur les investissement mais
pourtant l'affaire était rentable d'où
la question posée par les Français nous
sommes rentables mais nous voyons des
outils industriell disparaîtent car les
intérêts financiers ont pris le pouvoir
dans l'entreprise notre préoccupation
est aussi de s'intéresser à ce
qu'appelait le ce Grand Prix Nobel
Joseph Steve la cupidité de la finance
les excès de gourmandis détruisent des
outils industriels donc il faut poser
les problèmes dans tous les sens et
chercher des outils de modération la
modération c'est l'esprit du ministère
du redressement productif trisème
facteur c'est l'énergie et son prix ce
n'est pas une petite affaire car c'est
devenu un poids de plus en plus
important dans la
composition de la combinaison productive
le prix de l'énergie est un outil de la
compétitivité du socle industriel de la
base industriel France veillons à la
préserver dans ce qu'-là d'acquis et
veillons à imaginer des pistes futures
là aussi le gouvernement mènera dans le
débat sur l'énergie que mènera ma
collègue et ami Delphine bateau euh le
débat dans toutes ces acceptions dans
toutes ces possibilités sans aucun tabou
regardons les problèmes affrontons les
questions euh le prix des énergies
renouvelables c'est pour nous un
investissement majeur dans lequel nous
avons des filières industrielles
fondamentales que nous devons développer
et des futures filières dans lesquelles
nous espérons que la France sera leader
dans les années à venir mais nous avons
aussi d'autres sources euh euh de
d'énergie dont le prix est compétitif
que nous devons préserver cet équilibre
là fait partie de notre intelligence
collective veillons à mener le débat de
manière à ce que les décisions finales
soient les plus intelligentes deuxème
élément dans euh ce plan de reconquête
industrielle c'est la question du
financement monsieur le Président vous
avez posé la question euh des euh
de la banque publique d'investissement
pourquoi imaginons-nous un outil
public c'est un outil aujourd'hui qui
pourrait paraître superflu si le secteur
bancaire privé faisait son travail et
finançait correctement l'économie réelle
n'était pas préoccupé par des
rentabilités à court terme mais des
rentabilités à long terme que réclame
l'accompagnement du développement d'une
économie qui se construit sur le long
terme la patience et l'arme des
investisseurs mais l'impatience est
l'attribut du système financier cette
contradiction nous voulons la résoudre
en créant les conditions d'une
mobilisation de notre épargne dont le
poids l'importance est un des atouts
dans la mondialisation nous disposons
d'un des meilleurs taux d'épargne au
monde nous n'en faisons d'ailleurs pas
spécialement euh un attribut ou un outil
national euh nous laissons finalement
l'assurance vie euh qui accumule 1300 1
entre 1300 et 1500 milliards en cours
selon les calculs
euh de l'épargne défiscalisé avec le
soutien de l'État mais où va s'alouer
cette épargne quel investissement
finance-t-elle est-ce que nous pourrions
en débattre et poser ce problème notre
l'esprit de la BPI c'est d'abord de
clarifier pour les entreprises euh le
guichet de l'ensemble des solutions
existant aujourd'hui à la disposition
euh des entreprises vis-à-vis des
pouvoirs publics oo FSI et c'est un
rapprochement des lieux de décision
c'est-à-dire sur le terrain là où les
entreprises sont connues et les élus
locaux vont jouer un rôle important dans
euh ce cette j'allais dire prise de
décision de financement ils ne seront
pas seuls mais ils partageront l'analyse
la discussion et la la décision
d'engagement donc pour nous c'est une
banque qui se rapproche du modèle des
banques mutualistes des Landers
allemands où là la décision est
totalement décentralisée puisqu'il y a
un système de drainage de l'parne locale
notre projet est de conserver une
cohérence nationale mais d'augmenter les
possibilités d'engagement sur le
territoire on ne ira plus plider son
dossier FSI à Paris en essayant
d'expliquer des choses que n'importe
quel intervenant est capable de
connaître dès lors qu'il est sur le
terrain et c'est un ancien président du
conseil général qui vous le dit un
conseiller général d'un canton de 2000
âmes qui vous le dit
euh deuxème élément nous souhaitons que
cette banque publique d'investissement
ne se comporte pas comme une banque
privée mais une banque alternative ayant
d'autres une autre vision de
l'investissement une plus grande
patience une moindre gourmandise donc de
rechercher l'alternative à ce qui est
devenu le système financier nous allons
créer les circuits courts de l'épargne
ceux qui qui sont parmi vous des élus
ruraux savent ce que c'est sont que les
circuits courts euh vous allez financer
par votre épargne sur le livret
d'épargne d'industrie la PME que vous
connaissez la PME qui embauche vos
enfants la PME qui fait travailler vos
voisins votre village votre petite ville
votre sous-préfecture qui peut donner de
l'emploi à votre territoire et dont vous
consommez les produits dont vous admirez
euh les produits voilà ce ce que nous
pouvons euh faire avec cette banque
publique d'investissement rem mobilisant
les territoires autour en solidifiant
solidarisant les territoires autour des
entreprises euh bien sûr la question
euh de l'innovation est un sujet
fondamental beaucoup de choses ont
d'ailleurs été faites grâce au Grand
Emprunt je disais lorsque j'étais député
de l'opposition représentant spécial du
candidat François Holland qu'il faudrait
presque un grand emprunt par an
tellement les besoins sont immenses et
il est vrai que nous avons non pas
besoin d'endettement supplémentaire le
pays est maintenant surendetté et
l'effort que le ministère de l'économie
et des finances fait sur le redressement
des comptes hi pourvoi mais nous avons
besoin d'investir et nous avons besoin
d'attirer les investissements privés
d'utiliser les pouvoirs publics pour
mobiliser l'investissement public
parfois allié l'un à l'autre notre désir
est évidemment que un pays comme la
France et de manière plus générale le
continent européen invente les produit
de demain pour que nous ne soyons pas
les consommateurs des produits inventés
ou imaginés par d'autres continents et
que nous ne soyons pas sous la
dépendance technologique scientifique et
donc car des produits sont aussi des
actes culturels culturels
d'autres culture d'autres identités qui
ont parfaitement dans la circulation des
idées des biens et des services le droit
de citer mais nous ne pouvons pas
accepter un rapport de dépendance c'est
la raison pour laquelle le finance de
l'innovation technologique est un des
enjeux non seulement au plan national
mais aussi au plan local la rencontre y
compris dans des territoires où les
réseaux de PME aujourd'hui sont livrés à
elles-mêm nonont pas de grands groupes
pour les les soutenir ou les aider la
rencontre entre l'innovation
technologique les laboratoires de
recherche publiqu ou
privé la et et les
écosystème
d'entreprise local nous intéresse et
c'est c'est un des points sur lesquels
évidemment
nous
investirons le point suivant c'est aussi
la question de l'arbitrage dans nos
préférences collectives entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs bien
sûr on peut imaginer que nous sommes une
nation d'abord de consommateur qui ne se
préoccuperaiit pas de l'origine des
produits qui ne s'intéresseraient pas au
processus de production et qui
finalement se ruit sur le low cost sans
réfléchir l'évolution d'ailleurs des
modes de consommation sont là pour nous
dire qu'il y a des tendances profondes
dans la société mais je voudrais vous
faire part quand même d'un sursaut chez
le consommateur 60 à 65 % des
consommateurs selon une étude du CREDOC
déclar accepter de vouloir payer ou
d'accepter de payer plus cher un bien ou
un service dès lors qu'il est produit
sur la base industrielle France c'est un
changement fondamental ça veut dire que
le consommateur est devenu acteur est
devenu citoyen quand il pousse le cadis
de supermarché il s'intéresse à la
marchandise qu'il acquiert le pouvoir
d'achat est un objectif politique mais
le pouvoir d'achat au prix de la
destruction de nos outils de travail de
nos entreprises de nos emplois devient
suicidaire donc nous devons trouver le
point de réconciliation entre le
consommateur et le producteur c'est le
travail que nous faisons avec fleur pèin
sur la téléphonie mobile nous ne
souhaitons pas reprendre aux
consommateurs ce qu'ils ont obtenu et
acquis mais nous regardons la carte du
monde il y a aux États-Unis deux grands
opérateurs téléphoniques et deux petits
pour un continent en Chine il y a deux
opérateurs téléphoniques pour presque 1
milliard de futurs consommateurs de
téléphonie en Europe pour 300 400
millions d'habitants il y en a 140 donc
la balcanisation la concurrence libre et
non faussée presque sauvage aboutit et
aboutira à la perte de souverain dans le
numérique pour les Européens nous allons
être les consommateurs nous allons même
donner comme nous le faisons dans
facebook et Google nos données personnel
et nous les donnons en objet commercial
pour d'autres puissances notre
souveraineté numérique elle passe aussi
par la défense du producteur nous ne
pouvons pas être que des consommateurs
amoureux du court terme et regardons le
bilan d'ailleurs et faisons le bilan de
ces années low cost euh le low cost ce
sont les délocalisations dans
l'automobile le lowcost dans le
transport aérien ce sont les difficultés
d'Air France le lowcost dans la
téléphonie mobile ce sont les plans
sociaux il fallait l'imaginer quand même
chez SFR qui a réalisé des milliards de
marges et chez bug qui a eu une
tradition de rentabilité exceptionnelle
donc notre soin est évidemment dans les
arbitrages politiques que nous ferons
d'associer le Parlement à la discussion
publique sur où faisons-nous passer
l'équilibre voilà alors évidemment la
discussion elle sera multipartite nous
discuterons avec les syndicats parce que
il y a des syndicats dans ces
entreprises qui défendent des gens qui
vont se retrouver au chômage et qui il y
a ceux qui sont visibles dans les plans
sociaux puis ceux qui sont invisibles
les sous-traitants comme dans
l'automobile nous voulons discuter avec
eux nous allons discuter avec les
opérateurs qui eux cherchent à rétablir
leurs marge et leur dividendes nous
allons leur demander quelques efforts de
recapitalisation par exemple et puis il
y a les associations de consommateurs
qui disent vous nous retirez des acquis
de quel droit et pourquoi faire les
questions sont légitimes c'est cet
équilibre politique que nous allons
rechercher avec la Nation toute entière
en associant la population et donc
vous-même enfin dernier point je ne veux
pas être trop long monsieur le Président
c'est la question européenne et de la
réorientation de l'Union l'Union
européenne fait l'objet aujourd'hui
d'une prise de conscience de la part des
principaux dirigeants et nous pouvons de
cet hommage au président François
Hollande d'avoir
ouvert le débat de la croissance de
l'avoir installé au cœur de l'agenda
économique européen en pleine crise de
la zone euro la réorientation de l'Union
européenne c'est la préférence pour la
croissance plutôt que l'austérité et que
si des décisions de remise en ordre des
comptes publics doivent être prises il
vaut mieux qu'elles soi compensé par des
décisions de mobilisation de ressources
européennes pour favoriser la croissance
d'ailleurs c'est la stratégie de notre
de notre gouvernement que de toujours
éviter l'aggravation des problèmes en
croyant les améliorer car il a rien de
pire que la saigné de Molière qui tue le
malade en croyant le soigner c'est notre
préoccupation et bien en matière de
politique de la concurrence comme en
matière de politique commerciale
extérieure notre soin est aussi la
réorientation de l'Union européenne le
bloc
juridico-politique qui organise la
concurrence permanente entre les
Européens interdisant la naissance de
champions européens ou nationaux
deuxièmement favorisant toujours le
consommateur au détriment du producteur
conduit finalement euh les autres
puissances économiques à venir faire
leur shopping en Europe pour ramasser
les brevets les technologies les outils
de travail les et faire disparaître
évidemment les emplois au détriment des
territoires je ne dis pas que c'est là
l'attitude dominante ou permanente mais
c'est quand même aujourd'hui le risque
auquel nous exposions en fragilisant
notre tissu économique et industriel et
il en va de même s'agissant de la
politique commerciale ce que demande la
France et vous l'observerez bientôt dans
un certain nombre de dossiers qui vont
se présenter à nous c'est la réciprocité
ce que tout pays fait concurrent dans le
monde en
agissant de façon protectionniste en
manipulant sa monnaie
en aidant les entreprises en mobilisant
des ressources pour déformer finalement
les conditions de la concurrence en
vendant à perte ce qu'on appelle le
dumping social ou environnemental ce que
on l'Europe subit elle doit pouvoir s'en
défendre c'est la politique de
réciprocité la concurrence mondiale
déloyale doit être combatue et nous
l'assumons de façon tout à fait forte et
j'ai déjà pris un certain nombre
d'initiatives dans le domaine du conseil
de la compétitivité et avec l'aide d'un
certain nombre de ministres d'
l'industrie de l'Union européenne placer
souhaite placer au cœur des discussions
européennes à venir la question de la
réciprocité dans nos politiques
commerciales et de l'évolution de la
politique de la concurrence nous
demandons nous revendiquons le
droit vis-à-vis de nos concurrents
mondiaux déloyaux qui eux n'ont pas
Bruxelles pour les corriger que l'Europe
se consacre davantage à défendre les
Européens plutôt que les accabler voilà
l'esprit de ce ministère monsieur le
Président je répondrai maintenant
volontier aux questions des de mesdames
et messieurs les
sénateurs bien la parole est à Monsieur
Bourquin exceptionnellement pour 5
minutes
oui monsieur ministre au titre de
président du groupe industrie merci de
de votre exposé euh ne pensez-vous pas
pour aller à des questions
euh assez claires que le modèle
industriel passé est
dépassé
c'està-dire depuis la Libération
euh la politique du gouvernement a
consisté à aider les 40 grands groupes
et à tout baser la politique
industrielle sur les groupes du les
grands groupes du 440 on sent
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'autrees
choses des politique de filière faire en
sorte que les petites et moyennes
entreprises grandissent deviennent des
de taille intermédiaire et on sent bien
que les liens qui existent entre ces
grands groupes et les sous-traitants est
un problème crucial qui justement génère
de la
désindustrialisation c'est ma première
question la
seconde lorsquil y a des aides publiques
très
importantes je pense notamment à
l'automobile 10 à 11 milliards d'euros
avec l'ensemble taxes professionnelle
bonus malus prime à la casse est-ce
qu'il ne doit pas y avoir en des
contreparties solides tangibles avec
l'obligation de réindustrialiser le
territoire des politiques concertées
avec un état régulateur on sait très
bien que il y a l'indépendance de ces
grands groupe et pourquoi n'y a-t-il pas
plus de de comment de coopération entre
nos deux grands groupes français Peugeot
et Renault je je me suis jamais expliqué
cette question pourquoi N a il n'y
a-t-il pas
une plus grande coopération de entre ces
deux grands groupes dernière
question il y a un grave problème
industriel qui se
profile nous allons ramener notre mix
énergétique à 50 % de
nucléaire les énergies alternatives vont
monter en puissance comme jamais elles
n'ont monté pour l'instant ce sont les
Chinois les all et un peu les Japonais
qui ont la maîtrise industrielle de ces
énergies alternatives vous achetez une
chaudière à condensation
elle est assurément allemande vous
achetez des panneaux photovoltaïques
soit chinois soit allemand nous avons
peu et est-ce qu'il n'y a pas là un
volontarisme et je connais votre
volontarisme politique à mettre en place
pour que nous préparions ce futur mix
énergétique et nous créons les emplois
euh que dont nous avons besoin je prends
un exemple un seul exemple l'Allemagne a
créé
370000 emplois dans les énergies
nouvelles et nous nous avons une fière
photovoltaïque qui est à
l'agonie sur ces
questions-là je pense hein ce sont des
des questions extrêmement fortes j'ai
bien retenu votre plidoyer on sent qu'il
y a du volontarisme politique et il est
très important euh la la la politique
passée visant à traiter l'industrie
comme elle a traitée ne peut plus durer
et lorsqu'on a fait ce rapport sur
l'industrie avec plusieurs de mes
collègues une commission pluraliste on
veut refaire de l'industrie une question
centrale parce que la nation qui n'a pas
un socle industriel puissant n'aura pas
d'avenir au contraire elle va connaître
de graves
difficultés merci ah ben c'est très bien
tu as pas utilisé l'ensemble de ton
crédit temps monsieur Mirassou et
ensuite le noir merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais vous interpeller en ce qui me
concerne sur un problème plus local qui
concerne du reste à la fois département
de la Haute Garon et en même temps c de
l' il s'agit de l'entreprise laboratoire
Sanofi où pour faire vite tout en
affichant avec pas mal de cynisme des BF
relativement conséquent on explique que
ce profil à terme et bien la suppression
de sur Toulouse 650 640 postes de
chercheurs et encore plus mes collègues
de l'hérodison sur sur Montpellier et le
schéma est est toujours le même
c'est-à-dire que quand on qualifie un
écosystème de recherche de pas assez
pertinent et bien d'une part on se prive
de l'expertise des organisations
syndicales qui vont en quelque sorte
payer au prix fort cette cette cette
logique là sans avoir été au préalable
concerté la disqualification d'un
laboratoire de recherche avec quelques
molécules emblématiques au passage le
Plavix qui est un anticoagulant
conséquent et qui s'accorde du reste
assez mal avec la SAÉ que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure en citant citant Molia
parce que ça sera encore plus grave bon
toujours est-il que là il y a des fortes
interrogations et la direction de San
que j'ai rencontré que je vais
rencontrer à nouveau parle bien entendu
au conditionnel mais la pulsion qui est
la sienne c'est d'avoir recours en ce
qui concerne la recherche les brevets à
l'externalisation et on assisterait
quand même à une logique qui serait
relativement inconfortable qui
consisterait à se reposer sur les
molécules existantes qui rapportent mais
avec l'ombre portée des produits
génériques tout en se privant des moyens
de mettre sur le marché des nouvelles
molécules avOcatiOn thérapeutique sur
des pathologies qui ne sont pas encore
soignées et la question pratique que que
je vous pose c'est que est-ce que vous
allez interférer je sais que vous le
faites dans ce débat pour que le
dialogue social reprennne à la fois sur
le plan des orientations stratégiques de
Sanofi mais également sur le plan des
annonces éventuellement des décision à
court ou euh à moyen terme et en même
temps voir ce qu'il est possible de
faire dans ce secteur d'activité où
Sanofi prétend économiser 2 milliards en
coûte jusqu'à 2015 mais à force à force
à force il arriver un moment où les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques au niveau
de la recherche seront en panne et c'est
pas le moindre des mot s'agissant de ce
que vous av évoqué la perspective
d'issement productif un laboratoire qui
ne produit plus de recherche et bien par
définition il est hor jeux par rapport
au redressement productif que vous
appelez et que nous appelons de nos vœux
merci Monsieur Mirassou la parole à
Monsieur
Lenoir pour combien de temps monsieur le
Président 3 minutes 3 minutes très bien
comme tout le monde merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué trois thèmes dont un thème qui
est d'actualité dans notre haute
assemblée qui est celui de l'énergie de
l'actualité puisque la semaine dernière
la commission d'enquête sur le coût de
l'électricité a été amenée à rendre son
rapport alors vous soulignez avec raison
que l'énergie est un des piliers de
notre notre développement et de notre
redressement productif cela dit la
commission d'enquête a mis en évidence
que le coût de l'électricité en
particulier va fortement augmenter
diminuant à terme l'avantage compétitif
que nous tirons notamment du
nucléaire alors j'aimerais connaître vos
réflexions par rapport à ces indications
qui qui sont celles du Sénat mais
peut-être en avez-vous d'autres en en
développant
également la conséquence de tout cela
sur l'industrie
nucléaire les choix que le gouvernement
a annoncé qu'il
ferait vise à terme à diminuer la place
que l'industrie nucléaire occupe dans
notre pays avec toutes les conséquences
que ça implique vis-à-vis de pays qui
voi eux le nucléaire se développer il y
a a des bares de marché importantes à
conserver je pense notamment à la Chine
mais également au Brésil à l'Indonésie
voir à conquérir quelle est la place que
l'industrie nucléaire peut avoir à cet
égard
j'ajouteraiis qu'il y a deux thèmes je
suis toujours dans les 3 minutes
monsieur le Président je crois il y a
deux thèmes deux thèmes qu'il faut
rajouter monsieur le ministre d'abord
innovation recherche la différence avec
l'Allemagne je crois met en évidence
que nous avons je ne dis pas un retard
mais un décalage en France par rapport à
toutes les politiques qui sont menées en
Allemagne pour avoir des produits
nouveaux qui s'appuient sur une
recherche puissante et l'autre thème que
je souhaiterais vous voir développer
même si ce n'est pas votre domaine de
compétence il a été dévolu à notre
ancienne collègue qui a connu une
promotion je pense à Madame brick et
l'exportation la France est réputée pour
moins bien vendre que certain de
partenaires notamment l'Allemagne merci
merci la parole est à Roland corau oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaitais évoquer les
questions énergétiques notamment la
nécessité d'une filière industrielle
dans les énergies renouvelables mais
cela été traité par Martial Bourquin
puis je souhaitais évoquer le le coût de
l'énergie mais cela vient d'être traité
par notre collègue monsieur Lenoir don
que me resteil à dire simplement
monsieur le ministre je le dis tout net
j'ai appris i vos réactions dans le
sulfureux cas de Peugeot je crois qu'il
y a des vérités qui doivent être dites
vous les avez dites et moi je m'en
félicite car la question Peugeot a bien
été mise sous le tapis pendant les mois
avant la présidentielle ce n'est pas le
seul cas hélas il y a bien les Peugeot
il y a air France il y a sanonfi il y a
dou il y a pilpas à Carcasson alors il y
a des comportements effectivement à
redresser par exemple l'entreprise Pilpa
à Carcasson vous avez dit tout à l'heure
les excès de gourmandise du capital
détruisent les entreprises c'est très
juste monsieur le ministre Pilpa à
Carcassonne a été vendu récemment à une
filiale américaine du groupe R ice
crewing les Américains ont acheté cette
entreprise pour s'emparer des brevets
pour s'emparer des licences d'abord puis
du savoir-fire puis du portefeuille
client ils ont ensuite supprimé
l'activité recherche et dével ement en
fermant le laboratoire et enfin leur
opération terminée ils ont annoncé qu'il
fermaient l'entreprise afin de renforcer
les capacités de production ou ça en
Pologne c'est ce qui s'appelle
dépouiller un concurrent puis ensuite le
tuer sur l'Hôtel des profits financiers
et pourtant Pilpa a un taux de marge
brute de plus de 27 %. mais tant pis
pour les salariés nombreux qui vont
rester sur le carreau voilà donc un
comportement oui qui est inacceptable et
que je dénonce il y a véritablement des
choses à redresser monsieur le ministre
merci pour le soutien que vous pourrez
apporter sur ce dossier sous une forme
ou sur une
aautre ça tombe bien parce que j'ai une
autre réaction vis-à-vis de PSA que
celle de de de Roland moi je vous
connais pas et l'exposé que vous venez
de nous faire est un exposé auquel je
suis prêt à souscrire aussi bien sur la
politique de l'offre aussi bien sur la
politique européenne et cetera ce que
vous avez dit est frappé au coin du bon
sens mais j'ai trouvé que sur
PSA les propos étaient un peu choquants
et que finalement ministre du du
redressement productif est-ce qu'il y a
pas le risque en désignant la vindique
telle ou telle entreprise finalement de
jeter le propre sur toutes les
entreprises il y a des patrons voyou et
il faut les condamner et quand on doit
les condamner on doit les condamner au
tribunal médiatique mais on doit être
aussi capable
de les condamner devant la justice mais
c'est la question que je vous pose une
question de méthode je je suis assez
direct mais il y a un décalage je trouve
entre le le discours que vous nous
donnez et et auquel finalement je suis à
peu près sûr que les uns et les autres
on peut assez vite souscrire et puis
cette réaction là le le deuxième point
la question particulière sur le
financement je pense que ça sera très
lourd je crois que bal 3 comme solveny 2
pour les les assurances ont été très mal
négocié et ces règles prudentielles sont
appliquées avec encore plus de rigueur à
l'intérieur de l'Europe bien donc on on
va avoir des graves difficultés sur le
financement des entreprises en plus nos
plans de comptable poussent nos
entreprise à
sendêter la question elle est simple
quel est le niveau des engagements de
quelle enveloppe disposera annuellement
la la BPI je terminerai sur un domaine
aussi qui est M cher sur le numérique
j'ai j'ai bien entendu vos vos propos je
voudrais simplement les nuancer en
disant qu'aux États-Unis il y a le
triple play par exemple est plus de deux
fois plus cher qu'en France bon vous
dire aussi que il y a eu entre 300
350000 suppressions d'emploi pendant la
comment dirais-je la période de
consolidation de
concentration un peu bipolaire
d'ailleurs câble opérateur et opérateur
tout court aux États-Unis est-ce que
vis-à-vis des déclarations que vous avez
faites est-ce que vous comptez augmenter
le niveau des abonnement des usagers en
France est-ce que vous comptez remettre
en cause le système vous savez
d'abonnement sur 24 mois soit en rendant
plus coûteux le désistement au bout de
12 mois voilà ce que je voulais dire
tout en précisant que la succession de
loi consumériste n'avait pas eu mes
faveurs pendant des années mais je je
voulais poser cette question pour que
vous puissiez avoir l'opportunité de de
préciser votre
pensée je remercie en tous les cas les
inter intervenant de respecter la règle
qu'on s'était donné la semaine dernière
je trouve ça tout à fait remarquable ce
qui permet Claude Berry de bas de finir
la première salve de question monsieur
le ministre oui monsieur le ministre moi
aussi j'ai apprécié votre intervention
et il peut pas naître autemement puisque
nous avons soutenu je dirais les les
promesses ou les engagements qui ont été
faits pendant la campagne et je voudrais
revenir également sur un problème plutôt
local en sachant que j'ai interpellé
j'ai même combattu l'ancien gouvernement
et et le ministre antérieur de
l'industrie sur un problème qui se
passait en Bergeracois autour de la
Société Nationale des poudres et des
explosifs cette société a été privatisée
et le site de bergorac a été vendu à la
découpe aujourd'hui alors je reviendrai
pas sur ce qui a été fait c'est fait
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous avons
une partie de je dirais de de la
fabrication des poudres expclosifes euh
surtout à utilisation militaire euh qui
reste ça représente à peu près un peu
plus de 200 salariés c'est le groupe
erenco et ce
groupeenco alors je la différence avec
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
avant c'est que c'est quand même l'État
qui est actionnaire principal donc il
faudrait qu'il puisse donner l'exemple
euh ce groupe erenko est dépendant des
commandes militaires aujourd'hui il y
aurait une possibilité pour le site de
Bergerac ce serait de de créer de de
fabriquer du ne dans le groupe renco
fabrique mais dans d'autres productions
dans d'autres sites productifs il s'agit
d'un je dirais d'un d'un d'un produit
qui permet de de d'améliorer je dirais
le la la part le la part je dirais sur
l'environnement notamment du gasoil hein
dont il y aurait des possibilités à
à avec ce la fabrication de ce produit
de bergorac de diversifier l'activité et
de de permettre un certain nombre de de
de de salariés de pouvoir conserver leur
leur travail et de relancer un peu
l'activité de l'entreprise alors
j'aimerais savoir quelle est votre votre
vision sur cette problématique je sais
que vous êtes été vous avez été
interpellé par un certain nombre d'élus
du Bergeracois et notamment par le maire
de Bergerac Dominique Rousseau il y a
peu de temps
voilàci monsieur le ministre pour cette
première série de questions
vous avez la
parole merci de de de vos questions
euh incisive directe et je vais tâcher
d'être aussi efficace dans la réponse
que dans le questionnement
euh le lien évoqué par Martial Bourquin
entre les grands groupes et la
sous-traitance sont un sujet sur lequel
nous ne partons pas de rien un médiateur
de la sous-traitance a quand même fait
un gros travail je l'ai remercier
publiquement monsieur Jean-Claude Volot
car il a à lui tout seul créé je le dis
avec comment dire presque un humour
sérieux euh une agence de notation à lui
tout seul des donneurs d'ordre et à la
Une de challenge vous avez maintenant
les tremblements des comités exécutifs
et des directeurs des achats parce que
vous avez les notes les TOC du guide
Michelin des donneurs d'ordre qui a été
créé par Monsieur Volot donc je l'en ai
remercié parce que je crois qu'il a créé
une sorte de mise en jeu de la
responsabilité du donneur d'ordre par
rapport au au sous-traitants faut-il
aller plus loin nous allons voir les
effets de cette politique et j'invite la
représentation nationale le Sénat à se
pencher sur cette question je sais que
vous y travailler nous sommes
preneurs non pas de
lois qui serait finalement
déstabilisante mal travailler sous le
coup de l'émotion tel que nous avons
connu dans les périodes instables qui
nous ont précédé a mais plutôt de
réflexion sur comment unir des
entreprises entre elles nous avons
besoin à l'exportation Monsieur L nooir
en a dit un mot de chasser en meut donc
l'unité est préférable à la déchirure et
de ce point de vue les les grandes
entreprises ont besoin davantage dans
l'esprit du patriotisme économique le
ministère dont j'ai la charge défend à
chaque instant
euh avantage donner la main aux petites
entreprises s'agissant des aides
publiques qui vous l'avez souligné
monsieur Bourquin sont très importantes
nous demanderons des contreparties nous
vérifierons l'existence de ces
contreparties et nous veillerons à ce
que notre j'allais dire l'argent public
soit utilisé de façon efficiente d'abord
parce que nous en manquons il en a plus
beaucoup et que le peu que nous avons et
nous investissons dans l'industrie nous
souhaitons qu'il soit bien utilisé et
c'est une une des raisons pour
lesquelles dans la présentation que le
Président de la République m'a confié
demain du plan pour la filière
automobile il aura un volet
contreparti dont il n'était pas toujours
d'usage qu'il soit présent dans ce genre
de plan vous avez évoqué la coopération
Renault
PSA au moins vis-à-vis de la
sous-traitance elle existe car vous avez
finalement un partage implicite des
commandes selon les sites mais elle est
anarchique elle n'est pas travaillée
elle n'est pas concertée et elle est
assez éloignée du mot
coopération souvent j'ai vu pour sauver
quelques entreprises sous-traitan qui
donnaient des signes de difficulté sur
le territoire Renault répond si Peugeot
y va j'irai ou à l'inverse si Renault ne
fait pas ses caprices j'iraai donc donc
nous avons là je crois à imaginer
quelque chose de nouveau dans cette dans
ce travail entre les grands
constructeurs nos deux constructeurs
nationaux vous avez évoqué et là et là
pour le coup les idées nouvelles sont à
prendre le travail de conviction est à
faire tout est à imaginer euh vous avez
évoqué la question du nucléaire qui
réduisant sa part dans le mix
énergétique va conduire finalement les
Français à se tourner vers les énergies
alternatives les renouvelables et vous
signalez la grande faiblesse des
filières industrielles s'agissant du
photovoltaïque je dois vous dire que l'
industrie mondiale a été détruite par
l'offensive asiatique et
particulièrement chinoise les Allemands
les Espagnols ou les Français sont
exactement dans la même situation même
saint-gobin est en train de se retirer
de en tout cas se poser la question de
savoir s'il se retirre du
photovoltaïque nous avons subi des
graves déconvenus dans tous les secteurs
du photovoltaïque il y a eu les
allers-retours du précédent gouvernement
je je subventionne je ne subventionne
pas tarif de rachat pas de tarif de
rachat je l'augmente je le réduis c'est
une un une des causes de déstabilisation
mais pas seulement nous faisons face à
une
offensive de l'industrie chinoise qui ne
fait l'objet d'aucune protection de la
part de l'Union européenne résultat nous
sommes sur le point de acheter la
quasi-ttalité en Europe des panneaux
photovoltaïques au chinois nous avons
avec Delphine bateau commandé une
mission conseil général de l'Économie de
l'Industrie
des mines ancien conseiller général des
mines et du développement durable une
mission pour construire la politique au
regard des intérêt industriel du pays
c'est-à-dire un rapport entre si nous
reprenons le tarif de rachat est-ce que
cela nous aide à bâtir ou rebâtir sur
les technologies suivantes de rupture ou
incrémentale une réaction positive de
notre appareil industriel nous pourrions
d'ailleurs le faire dans tous les
secteurs nous avons une politique à la
Conférence nationale de l'industrie
de filière qui nous permet d'avoir une
observation fine secteur par secteur des
points de reconquête concret et là où il
faut trouver des technologies des
investisseurs des industriels parfois
partir de rien mais la créativité
française est un atout extraordinaire je
la cite souvent en exemple parce que
nous avons partout des des gens qui
veulent investir il leur manque souvent
plus l'argent que les idées les process
et les technologies monsieur mir a
évoqué le le dossier Sanofi qui pour moi
est
significatif de ce que ne doit pas faire
un grand groupe qui a réalisé 5
milliards de profits de bénéfice je ne
confonds pas le bénéfice et le chiffre
d'affaires l'année dernière 200 milliard
4 au premier semestre 2012 et qui a
l'intention en effet de procéder à la
destruction d'un certain nombre
d'emplois notamment dans la recherche et
le développement le pire puisque c'est
le meilleur moyen de se priver pour un
grand groupe créateur
de molécules innovantes d'avenir donc
j'ai fait savoir à la fois la direction
au Président Directeur Général monsieur
lajou la nécessité de négocier ces
décisions et de tenir compte de du
facteur humain et donc de passer un
accord avec les organisations syndicales
s'il n'y a pas d'accord avec les
organisations syndicales je n'ai aucune
raison dans une entreprise aussi
profitable d'accepter la moindre
destruction d'emploi et d'ailleurs j'ai
dit à la j'éta qui est venu me voir
pendant la grande conférence sociale qui
m'a questionné sur sanofice je leur dit
soyez constructif car une entreprise a
besoin de se réorganiser c'est un
organisme vivant fait avancer les choses
mais euh nous ne voulons pas accepter
euh des destructions d'emploi qui ne
seraient pas rendu j'allais dire
nécessairire ou comprise comme t par le
personnel donc il s'agit de trouver des
compromis et de les rendre j'allais dire
euh positif pour tout le monde surtout
lorsque l'entreprise est profitable et
Sanofi est une grande entreprise
française qui doit le rester monsieur le
noir pose la
question de l'industrie nucléaire je
l'ai déclaré devant la Conférence
nationale industrie le Premier ministre
également nous avons confiance dans
l'industrie nucléaire nous considérons
que ce n'est pas parce que nous allons
en réduire le poids dans le mix
énergétique et notamment en raison de
l'augmentation importante de la
consommation d'énergie sur notre
territoire national dans les 10 15 20
prochaines années que cela signifie que
le nucléaire fera l'objet d'une sorte de
déprise ou d'abandon bien au contraire
nous affirmons confiance le gouvernement
affirme sa confiance dans l'industrie
nucléaire travaille à améliorer avec
l'autorité indépendante de sûreté
toujours la sûreté nous rejetons
l'esprit lowcost dans le nucléaire et
l'industrie nucléaire et nous défendons
l'amélioration toujours permanente de
cette industrie
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous croyons dans la force exportatrice
de notre industrie nucléaire voilà je ne
peux pas vous dire plus clairement mais
c'est l'esprit dans lequel je ne cesse
de m'exprimer depuis que je suis en
charge de cette belle mission vous
évoquez la question de l'exportation de
l'innovation la ministre déléguée auprès
de moi fleur pèlerin chargé de
l'innovation est
attentif évidemment à l'investissement
public dans innovation publique privé
d'ailleurs et à la diffusion
c'est-à-dire il ne s'agit pas seulement
d'innover il s'agit de transformer cette
innovation en produit industriel de
demain ce travail de transmission et la
faiblesse française les Allemands à
travers le programme franofer ont pris
non pas de l'avance mais ont montré leur
leur le chemin nous pourrions dire en la
matière c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous imaginons avec nos
nombreux acteurs dans la suite
d'ailleurs des institut carneau qui ont
été créés par le grand emprunt une
montée en puissance des programmes de
diffusion technologique de confrontation
croisement mise en commun de la création
technologique et du processus industriel
donc il y aura des rencontres sur les
territoires sur vos territoires et pour
nous le territoire est l'avenir de la
France c'est une des ressources il n'y a
pas que les métropoles même si certains
d'entre vous sont élus par des
territoires métro mopolisin ou
métropolitain métropolisé ou
métropolitain il y a aussi des
territoires avec une grande activité
économique qui ne sont pas urbains et
qui ont montré leur dynamisme économique
sachons utiliser ces atout et j'y suis
personnellement très attaché à travers
la politique de pôle de compétitivité
que nous souhaitons continuer à soutenir
l'exportation la BP pour nous doit avoir
et cela fait partie du débat que nous
aurons au Parlement au sein du
gouvernement donc nous n'en sommes qu'au
prémis doit avoir un volet de
financement aussi de l'exportation euh
fonds propres
euh innovation AUO donc fonds propres
haut de bilan
FSI innovation l'ancienne envar qui est
dans
haoso besoin fond de roulement auoso
c'est-à-dire finalement tout ce que
ferait une banque privée un fond
d'investissement dans un seul guichet
unique qui changera la vie des
entreprises puis peut-être également
exportation c'est la question de la
cofas qui a été privatisée et est-ce que
celle-ci revient dans le giron de la BPI
c'est la question que nous posons vous
posez les questions sur les masses sur
lesquelles nous anticipons je crois
c'est vous monsieur Lenoir à moins que
ce soit monsieur
rillo
les
les ressources de la BPI nous imaginons
une un budget innovation à 250 millions
d'euros qui est le budget d'Oséo
aujourd'hui en fond propre FSI pour
l'instant en est un demi mililliard sur
les prêts nous sommes entre 12 disons
une dizaine de milliards d'en cours ce
qui pourrait constituer le noyau dur et
une dizaine de milliards de garanties de
prêt bancairire quant aux ressources du
livré DESP industrie tout cela est en
débat rien n'est tranché euh j'allais
dire les sénateurs doivent s'en mêler et
nous nous donner leur leur sentiments
quand nous les concerterons quand nous
vous con CER
euh s'agissant de Peugeot monsieur
retillo me reproche maises mes mes mes
déclarations ce sont déclarations
extrêmement modérées et par ailleurs
parfaitement équilibrées et je voudrais
vous les citer si vous voulez bien
euh d'abord le fait que il y ait eu
dissimulation n nié par personne et
reconnu par Monsieur Varin lui-même et
de dissimulation d'ailleurs je le dis
qui ont été crédibilisé c'est mon propos
par le gouver gouvernement précédent
pourquoi crédibiliser parce que lorsque
finalement on a des syndicats qui ont
mis à jour découvert un document de
travail annonçant la fermeture d'olenet
qui date du mois d'août 2010 et que dans
ce document il est inscrit que la
fermeture la meilleure fenêtre pour
riser la fermeture c'est après les
élections 2012 et que en 2011 alors que
ce document est public le président de
la République lui-même qui vient de
recevoir le président euh du groupe
PSA en novembre 2011 déclare qu'il n'y
aura pas de plan social en France chez
PSA nous nous sommes en droit de dire
qu'il y a une forme d'irresponsabilité
du pouvoir précédent dans la mesure où
soit il y avait une
nécessité de euh mettre sur la table ces
difficultés et de les traiter et donc de
ne pas les laisser
s'aggraver et dans ce cas-là il fallait
le faire et avoir ce courage politique
soit il n'y avait pas de nécessité alors
pourquoi finalement
aujourd'hui nous les demander donc et
par ailleurs je voudrais juste vous dire
que vis-à-vis des questionnements que le
Ministre en charge que je suis est en
droit de poser à l'actionnaire
l'actionnaire n'est pas quelqu'un qui
n'a pas de responsabilité dans la
situation il prend des décisions j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que pour moi le
redressement productif c'était la triple
responsabilité et l'équilibre de ces
responsabilité l'actionnaire est
responsable nous préférons des
stratégies industrielles plutôt que des
stratégies financières distribuer des
dividendes au moment même où on commence
à brûler du cash je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité de l'actionnaire
questionner c'est éviter que euh ces
erreurs se reproduisent ne serait-ce que
parce que il est plus difficile un
actionnaire de dire je prépare euh un un
la fermeture de l'au NAET mais en même
temps je distribue des dividendes aux
actionnaires il y a là une contradiction
qui n'est pas euh qui est difficile à
expliquer euh y compris aux salariés euh
de Peugeot quje dit sur France interre
qui est plus choqué il y a des plans
sociaux
dans lesquels nous pouvons considérer
qu'il est inévitable d'accepter des
pertes d'emploi pour sauver l'entreprise
pourquoi parce qu'à Peugeot si le malade
n'est pas imaginaire donc je n'ai donc
pas dit que le malade était imaginaire
contrairement à ce qu'on prête est
vraiment réel et bien il y a quand même
80000 personnes qui travaillent qui
restent chez Peugeot et nous avons
charge de les aider à garder leur emploi
et nous voulons que Peugeot retrouve la
bonne santé financière il y a une
responsabilité de l'actionnaire et
j'appelle à la responsabilité
industrielle de l'actionnaire il y a une
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
pour ne pas que ce soient les salariés à
l'égard desquels toute entreprise a une
dette euh paye le prix exclusivement du
sacrifice il doit avoir lieu il y a une
responsabilité économique du syndicat
qui doit ne pas j'allais dire euh qui
doit tenir compte de la réalité
économique si Peugeot a des difficultés
nous les constaterons nous les
évaluerons et nous ferons en sorte que
les mesures soient proportionnées à ces
difficultés voilà notre politique c'est
une politique j'allais dire vous l'avez
dit vous-même frappée au coin du bon
sens je vous remercie de cette ce
compliment que je prends comme tel mais
je crois que notre projet n'est pas de
dissimuler n'est pas de mentir il est
d'affronter ensemble si vous voulez
mobiliser la nation dans ses
composantes les territoires les
organisations syndicales les
entrepreneurs le patronnat les sénateurs
les députés les élus locaux les citoyens
il faut regarder les problèmes les
identifier les mesurer et ensuite
trouver les solutions ensemble les
surmonter je n'ai pas d'autres méthodes
c'est une méthode d'inspiration
mandziste voilà excusez-moi j'aime citer
pierre mandz France il n'a pas été
sénateur je crois il a été député
personne n'est parfait personne n'est
parfait mais je le cite quand même parce
que il reste quand même celui qui dans
des périodes de crise politique ou
diplomatique a dit la vérité et donc ça
a permis aux Français de surmonter la
difficulté c'est ce que nous voulons
faire dans cette période très critique
sur le plan économique et sociale que
nous nous avons à affronter
ensemble je voudrais encore dire un mot
monsieur le Président parce que vous
m'avez interrogé vous-même sur le projet
de loi sur l'encouragement à la reprise
de sites dont la viabilité est
avérée là encore c'est d'actualité c'est
d'actualité nous n'acceptons pas que des
groupes qui dispose de comme l'a demandé
la l' exposé tout à l'heure monsieur
court qui dispose finalement qui ont
profité d'une certaine manière
d'investissement qui eux-mêmes ont fait
fructifier leur investissement et dont
la rentabilité est
avérée qui ont d'ailleurs dont des
territoires ont eux-même profité avec
lesquels il y a eu un j'allais dire une
alliance positive
que dès lors que il y a un repreneur
qu'il y a un industriel ils nous disent
moi je ferme je m'en vais parce que je
vais fabriquer ailleurs cette stratégie
là est inacceptable pour les Français et
pour n'importe quel gouvernement quel
qu'il soit donc nous
souhaitons finalement organiser en
quelque sorte la reprise et la favoriser
l'encourager s'il y a un repreneur c'est
que l'affaire est rentable d'ailleurs je
ne connais pas de repreneur qui n'it pas
fait les diligences permettant les du
diligigences permettant de vérifier que
son inv
tisement serait pertinent ou inconsidéré
donc c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
dlors qu'il y a un repreneur c'est donc
que le choix de délocaliser l'activité
ou de la stériliser n'est pas acceptable
voilà comment la République va se
réarmer elle a besoin de se réarmer face
au tout libéral au laisser faire dans
l'affaire PIPA monsieur le
sénateur j'ai bien l'atention euh euh
d'imaginer des
solutions qui éviteraient que finalement
le site disparaisse he il faut que le
site se maintienne donc nous allons
mettre tout en œuvre ce qui dans dans
nos possibilités pour que vous ayez des
réponses à vos inquiétudes dans une
région qui a besoin
d'industrie merci le seule question
c'était de savoir dans quel calendrier
çait s'inscrire parce que il me semble
qu'il y a une urgence concernant ce
genre de reprise d'entreprise euh il
nous reste 8 demandes de parole je sais
Monsieur le Ministre devaz nous quitter
à
18h15 et donc je vous demande mes chers
collègues de rétrécir à 2 minutes vos
interventions madameen ça tomb
mal d'abord c'est Madame ass à6 c'est à
à l'Assemblée nationale
oui d'abord je voudrais remercier
Monsieur le Ministre pour ces propos qui
sont vraiment en rupture avec ce que
nous avons pu entendre les mois les mois
passés et qui sont marqués d'une
ambition en matière de de de
reconquête industrielle et permettez-moi
parce que je suis sénatrice de la SA
sanie d'évoquer plus particulièrement
bien évidemment la situation de PSA de
façon générale parce que supprimer 8000
emplois dans l'industrien automobile
c'est une catastrophe pour le pays et
bien évidemment pour un territoire comme
la SC ni c'est aussi une catastrophe
puisque cela va toucher des milliers de
familles dans notre département
et et et au-delà donc moi j'aurais des
questions précises monsieur le ministre
le le président du directoire de PSA a
réitéré sa volonté de de
de que chaque employé soit salarié de
PSA soit euh enfin qu'il y ait une
solution qui soit trouvée pour ch chacun
des employés de de PSA et donc qu' n'y
aurait pas de licenciement sec moi
j'aimerais savoir si vous en avez en
tout cas la si vous avez la capacité d'y
répondre sous quel statut social vont
être repris ces salariés et puis bien
évidemment on oublie on parle des
contrats à durée indéterminé mais on
oublie bien bien trop souvent les
intérimaires qui sont très nombreux sur
le site d'oleny et qui sont
particulièrement des jeunes gens euh à
propos desquels on dit pique pendre mais
qui ont soif d'apprendre et soif de
travailler et euh donc je je je voulais
savoir si vous aviez entamé une
réflexion à ce sujet euh la deuxième
chose c'est
euh ce matin nous avons reçu Monsieur je
vais oui je vais réduire monsieur Pichon
qui est responsable des relations
responsable de PSA des relations avec le
Parlement qui nous a dit contrairement à
monsieur retayo qui effectivement par ce
que dit Monsieur retayo qu'
effectivement il y a plusieurs scénaris
avaient été évoqués en son temps et donc
je lui ai rappelé que les syndicats
avaient dévoilé bah ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui puis je vous rappelle
monsieur rettaillot que mon groupe avait
obtenu au Sénat un débat sur la filière
automobile et que ce débat a eu lieu au
mois de février dernier et que nous
avons évoqué très largement le cas de de
de de PSA donc ce n'est une surprise
pour personne et moi j'iraai plus j'irai
plus loin que ce qu'a dit Monsieur le
Ministre la direction du de PSA a
volonirement menti sur la situation donc
parmi les scénarios évoqués il y avait
celle de l'attribution d'un nouveau
véhicule au site d'oln sousbois et qui
aurait nousons permis de préserver des
emplois jusqu'en 2024 et donc ce
scénario n'a pas été retenu par la
direction de PSA je je je voulais que
vous nous en disiez quelques mots et je
vais arrêter là mon propos parce que le
ministre a déjà dit des chos parole est
à Madame
lard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord permettez-moi de
m'associer à mon collègue Bruno
rotaillot pour dire que bien sûr on ne
peut que s'associer à la démarche que
vous nous présentez et qui vise à
dans le cadre d'une réalité industrielle
qui est devant nous et qui va être
extrêmement complexe va nécessiter un
travail de concertation un travail où
chaque acteur chaque acteur les pouvoirs
publics les industriels les partenaires
sociaux auront tous un rôle déterminant
et complémentaire à jouer et si je me
permets maintenant d'entamer la deuxième
partie de mon propos avec un peu plus
nuance c'est parce que comme ma collègue
qui vient de s'exprimer je viens comme
vous le savez d'un territoire qui est
directement concerné puisque je viens du
du Valenciennois où se situe l'usine
Sevelnord PSA Sevelnord qui pour
l'occasion fait l'objet bien sûr
d'inquiétude par rapport à son avenir
depuis plus d'une année et a fait
l'objet depuis plus d'une année pour les
mêmes raisons hein il s'agit là non pas
on va dire d'un défaut ou domomission de
la part de Peugeot mais tout simplement
d'un abandon de partenariat de la
société Fiat qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
cette unité de production ne bénéficie
plus d'une capacité suffisante pour pour
continuer à produire dans de bonnes
conditions si elle ne trouve pas un
nouveau véhicule à produire avec dans
une situation transitoire la possibilité
d'avoir une production de véhicule
utilitaire il y avait plusieurs
conditions j'ai lu la presse j'ai les
informations à réunir j'ai bien entendu
ce qu'il fallait une des premières
conditions c'était que la rupture avec
Fiat soit bien prononcée et réglée c'est
le cas trouver un nouveau partenariat
rapide pour produire un véhicule
utilitaire Toyota s'est mobilisé ce
travail il y a plusieurs mois qu'il a
été entamé de recherche par PSA avec
aussi on peut le dire un gouvernement
qui s'est inquiété de la situation tout
n'est pas résolu mais ces deux premiers
aspects le sont ma question maintenant
elle pose sur euh et bien la troisème
étape l'étape c'est comment on fait en
sorte que cette ligne ce véhicule
utilitaire futur qui sera nécessaire un
véhicule utilitaire hybride puisse se
fabriquer dans le valenciénois plutôt
qu'en Espagne en clair comment on fait
pour réduire l'écart de compétitivité il
y a deux aspects le travail de
concertation que vous devez engager que
PSA doit engager avec les partenaires
sociaux sur l'activité salariée et il y
a un deuxième volet monsieur le ministre
qui nous concerne tous les élus l'État
que vous êtes les régions mais aussi les
collectivités c'est comment nous sommes
aujourd'hui en capacité dans le cadre de
comités de suivi régionaux de nous
mettre autour de la table et de dire
concr contitement comment chacun va
pouvoir accompagner cette réduction des
coûts et cette installation d'une
nouvelle unité de production et une
question se pose juste une une petite
question jeement de 2 minut pour
recherche donc si vous voulez que lesè
question sachant que le ministre par
part à 18h15 na vrai mais euh
madame merci monsieur le Président je
vais essayer d'être bre j'ai trois
petites questions monsieur le ministre
merci d'abord pour votre propos
liminaire qui qui nous réjouit quelque
peu par votre volontarisme euh dans
l'alliier 100 entreprises environ vive
de la sous-traitance automobile qui
emploie
4500 salariés lors de ce débat du 23
février j'avais posé la question de la
sous-traitance dont vous venez de parler
je voudrais préciser souvent la
sous-traitance mais vous le savez est
mal menée par les constructeurs et est
considéré souvent malheureusement comme
variable d'ajustement de leur chiffre d'
affair pourtant les sous-traitants sont
à l'origine de la plupart des grandes
réussites industrielles de la filière
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas monsieur
le ministre qu'au-delà des bonnes
pratiques entre clients et fournisseurs
il ne faudrait pas aller vers un
véritable statut de la sous-traitance
industrielle pour rééquilibrer et
peut-être soumettre ses contrats au
contrôle de l'égalité ça c'était ma
première question ma deuxième question
c'est euh suite à ce que vous venez de
dire sur le nucléaire est-ce que ne
faudrait-il pas aller vers limiter plus
drastiquement la sous-traitance dans le
nucléaire puisque pour des raisons de
sûreté de sécurité et la troisème
question c'est très local c'est l'usine
JPM qui fabrique des serrures à verme je
vais donc raccourcir 461 personnes en
2009 on va voir en Chine pour installer
une entreprise tout va bien puisque
cette entreprise est florissante
progression de 22 % de son chiffre
d'affaires et demain matin plus personne
à àverme donc moins 400 personnes sans
doute tout cela va aller soit en Chine
soit dans une autre localisation je
voulais savoir d'abord monsieur le
ministre le président du Conseil général
de l'Allier vous a demandé un
rendez-vous pour ce sujet est-ce que
vous allez nous répondre et comment
peuvent intervenir et peut intervenir le
commissaire dont vous avez parlé de
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
nous préciser son rôle justement dans
dans ce cas-là est-ce qu'on doit le
mobiliser travailler avec lui comment on
peut travailler avec lui sur des sujets
tels que je viens de vous l'évo merci
madame monsieur Vergos
oui monsieur le ministre deux questions
au moment où on cherche des des idées
pour
euh trouver de la richesse faire de la
la production industriel nous avons
assisté récemment à un débat sur la PCP
la politique commune de la pêche et s' a
une industrie qui est porteuse encore
c'est celle de la pêche quoi qu'on en
pense n'oublions pas que la France est
la
deuxè nation au monde par sa superficie
maritime 11 millions de kilmè Carr
première question monsieur le ministre
est-ce que vous allez j'allais dire
enfin non puisque c'est la première fois
que la République dispose d'un ministre
du redressement productif est-ce que
vous allez vous mêler concrètement à à
cette bataille de l'industrialisation du
pays au cœur de l'Europe parce
que nous avons un sentiment largement
partagé que le nous jouons petit
bras face à l'Europe dans cette affaire
nous n'occupons pas notre juste place au
travers de nos territoires ultrabarins
et enfin 2uxème question qui est propre
alors à euh mon ma région vous avez
peut-être déjà désigné vous allez
désigner 22 commissaires au redressement
productif vous savez que la France la
nation compte 26 régions il en manque
quatre seront-elles comblées
ok monsieur Dubois oui merci monsieur le
Président alors trois questions à
Monsieur le Ministre tout en sachant je
rejoins tout à fait les propos qui ont
été tenus par mes deux collègues Bruno
rotillot et Valérie lard je pense que la
stratégie de reconquête industrielle
prendra beaucoup de temps qu'il y aura
certainement deux phases il y a une
phase d'urgence dans laquelle vous vous
situez mais il y a certainement une
deuxième phase dira qui sera battir et
moi j'invite je dirais un Grenel de la
réindustrialisation qui mettra je DIRIS
en phase sur la durée un un certain
nombre d'actions nécessaires mais pour
se faire faut-il que l'industrie et
l'entreprise et les entrepreneurs soient
respecté dans le pays et considéré comme
une force et non pas comme une faiblesse
je viens de lire un sondage dernièrement
où 57 % des Français ne veulent surtout
plus plus prendre de risqu aujourd'hui
et je pense que c'est en prenant des
risques qu'on créeit de la richesse que
l'on innve de deux questions rapides
votre position sur le gaz de schiste
monsieur le ministre m'intéresserait
parce que je dirais le mix énergétique
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure faut-il
s'assoir je dirais sur cette énergie
peut-être du futur je mets un point
d'interrogation mais peut-être faut-il
quand même s'y intéresser et puis deème
question vous avez dit que le coût du
travail et le coût de la protection
sociale
était un un enjeu qu'il fallait pas
ignorer il fallait se poser toutes les
questions alors pourquoi avez-vous
supprimé je dirais dans le gouvernement
la TVA sociale avant finalement d'avoir
fait le
diagnostic la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre monsieur le ministre merci d'être
devant
nous étant sur le département des
vauches département très sinistré sur le
plan industriel qui a déjà fait l'objet
de reconversion en près le plan textile
il a 20 25 ans et souvent ce sont des
des sous-traitants de l'industrie
automobile qui s'y sont installés et qui
aujourd'hui euh vous connaissez la
l'actualité TRW qui est en grosse
difficulté dans un autre domaine dans
mon canton j'entends dire par exemple
cordon ri
ruriiminil le leader de la fabrication
de ficell agricole en Europe et en
difficulté il c'est en train de se faire
ronier par le Portugal qui est capable
de fournir des produits fis à peu près
au M niveau que les produits industriels
pour fabriquer dans à l'entrée
d'entreprise beaucoup de j'ai le cas
aussi dans mon canton d'une entreprise
et ça c'est ça fait partie de vos soucis
j'aiai bien compris qui gagnait de
l'argent c'était une entreprise de
Lactalis qui avait acheté il y a 10 ans
une laiterie chez moi qui avait 300
personnes et qui a décidé il y a
seulement 3 mois de descendre le lait en
Italie pour le fabriquer en fromage
beaucoup plus rentable que le monst des
Voges ou autrees donc voilà quand même
des on est en train de perdre perdre
tout notre potentiel de travail et a
l'agriculture produit mais la valeur
transformation tout ça quitte quitte nos
villages quitte nos notre ruralité et on
est très inquiet là-dessus alors
qu'est-ce que vous envisagez par exemple
comme pour TRW qui est quand même une
entreprise américaine que vous
connaissez probablement mieux que moi
mais qui nous pose des soucis là il y a
deux entreprises dans cette vallée là la
vallée va être fermée totale il y aura
plus d'entreprises le plus gros Faur
aura peut-être une quinzaine d'employés
alors qu' avec un entreprise de 350
ouvriers merci je su pas
plusci jaqu piierre d'avoir respecté
pratiquement son temps Yannick
vugrenard merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
développement que vous avez fait tout à
l'heure Valérie surtout et et le fait
qu'il semble-t-il un consensus sur ce
que vous avez dit globalement et sur la
manière aussi de permettre un
développement de notre industrie sur le
territoire national le fait que semble-
il y a un consensus quelque chose de
très important dans la période que nous
traversons deux points le premier local
mais qui a des incidences nationales
évidentes c'est la question de la
construction navale je sais votre
intérêt à défendre cette industrie
actuellement
laasncm qui est la société qui s'occupe
de relier la Corse au continent est en
voie de passer commande de H navires
dont quatre à très court terme il n'y a
plus que trois chantiers qui sont sur
les rangs STX à saint-azer un chantier
sud-coréen et un chantier japonais donc
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
le fait que dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent la décision devoir
être prise et donc je souhaite que le
gouvernement pèse de tout son poid pour
qu'elle aille bien entendu dans dans le
bon sens deuxème point pour être
toujours très court euh vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure la question de de la
banque publique d'investissement est-ce
que au niveau des des régions également
il y aura une logique de déconcentration
aussi des décision dans un souci de de
plus grande et de meilleure efficacité
au plus proche des petites et moyennes
entreprises
merci la parole à Claude dyin pour la
dernière question merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre et là je
vais je vais revenir sur les les
conséquences de l'éventuelle formeture
de l'usine PSA d'oleny pas au niveau des
salariés puisque vous avez très
clairement exprimé votre volonté de de
modifier le le plan social qui n'est
inacceptable en l'état mais au niveau
territorial il y a à côté de la ville
d'oln une ville qui s'appelle Sevran
qu'on ne voit pas dans les pages
économiques mais qu'on voit dans les
fait est dans la pauvreté qui est devenu
un symbole de pauvreté cette ville avait
une richesse elle avait deux entreprises
Kodak et westing House qui ont fermé
sans aucun remplacement sans aucun sans
aucune
r industrialisation merci
euh je je crains fort que si l'usine
d'olnet ferme comme ça brut de
décoffrage la ville d'olnaet devienne la
ville de Sevran et ça ce serait
dramatique
merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci de de vos
questions que se passe-t-il sur le plan
social de de Peugeot d'abord je trop tôt
pour répondre et j'ai demandé à Monsieur
Emmanuel Sartorius de mener un audit au
côté de celui des organisation syndicale
sur la situation réelle de Peugeot qui
rendra son rapport le 31 juillet c'est
dans quelques jours le gouvernement
évidemment sait lire les comptes regarde
les informations duement accrédité
conformément aux règles relatives aux
informations d'entreprise côté en bourse
néanmoins nous souhaitons avoir une
analyse approfondie sur deux plans le
premier c'est la réalité économique de
l'entreprise ses
difficultés la profondeur de ces
difficultés et en faire une mesure
j'allais dire de manière à partager le
diagnostic avec tous que nous soyons
tous d'accord et donc notre expert
monsieur Sartorius se tient au côté des
organisations syndicales pour mener en
quelque
sorte ce débat de manière à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas d'un côté la thèse de la
direction Peugeot et la thèse des
organisation syndicale il doit y avoir
partage des informations et d'une
certaine façon analyse partagée c'est
l'objectif du gouvernement car nous
serons plus forts si nous partageons le
diagnostic pour rechercher les
meilleures solutions pour que ce ne soit
pas des solutions ni excessives euh ni
euh dangereuses pour la stratégie future
de l'outil industriel Peugeot le
deuxième volet dont Monsieur Sartoux est
chargé et
concerne la 2ème partie de sa mission
qu'il rendra à la rentrée au 15
septembre où nous avons demandé à
Monsieur sartodus d'examiner la
stratégie développement de Peugeot les
alliances avec
GM la stratégie dans un marché qui est
quand même relativement dépris sur le
plan européen sa stratégie de
localisation la remontée en
gamme son positionnement par rapport au
locost par rapport au premium cela
mérite avec la quantité d'ê publique que
finalement les contribuables ont soit
donné à aux constructeurs nationaux soit
qu'ils donneront indirectement dans le
plan filière automobile que nous soyons
en accord avec la stratégie de Peugeot
que nous puissions accompagner le rebond
la Renaissance les retrou ille avec la
prospérité de Peugeot de manière à ce
que les ouvriers les CADES les
ingénieurs qui auront perdu leur travail
qui aiment tant ou qui aiment leur
entreprise puissent s'ils le
perdent peut-être retrouver leur
entreprise plus tard il y a des
violences dans l'histoire cyclique de
l'industrie automobile que nous
observons tant en Europe qu'aux
États-Unis il y a des destructions
d'emploi des réembauches donc il n'y a
pas de fatalité soyons intelligent par
rapport à l'avenir de Peugeot et c'est
le sens
de l'action du gouvernement et de de son
travail donc je ne peux pas répondre au
mesures sociales ou aux mesures de
réindustrialisation ou aux mesures
envisagé tout le monde a des idées mais
pour l'instant moi j'en suis au
diagnosticque et lorsque nous arriverons
ensuite à la discussion et la
négociation doit laisser la place au
dialogue social l'examen toutes les
alternative et c'est le rôle de la
négociation d'un plan social donc nous
aurons au mois de septembre cette
discussion sur l'avenir d'olnaet si
Henet est abandonné ou au contraire si
Henet est maintenu il y a des choix qui
ont été fait ces choix doivent être euh
qui sont proposés par Peugeot doivent
être expertisés avant que le
gouvernement n une position voilà donc
je ne peux pas répondre à vos questions
je sais que les élus souhaitent rassurer
les salariés de cette région il n'y a
pas d'ailleurs que les salariés de
Peugeot il y a tous les sous-traitants
autour je le sais mais chaque chose en
son temps et pour le gouvernement pour
l'instant c'est un travail sur l'étendue
des difficultés de Peugeot madame
l'étard rvoque svel Nord là il y a un
accord il est je crois public entre
Toyota et PSA la question est de savoir
comment il est accompagné c'était votre
question il est tôt trop tôt pour le
dire parce que l'accord entre BSA et
Toyota est en cours de finalisation ce
que nous voyons c'est qu'il faut un
accord de tout le monde syndicat de la
direction de Peugeot des pouvoirs
publics des collectivités locales donc
nous ferons ce travail euh à la suite la
rentrée de l'annonce par PSA et et
Toyota de leur de leur désir de coopérer
ensemble autour de ce site
euh voilà où nous en sommes pour
l'instant je ne peux pas vous en dire
davantage au lieu et place de la société
PSA euh madame Church des sénatrice de
l'alliier évoque la question d'une
entreprise qui d'ailleurs fait l'objet
d'un suivi par le commissaire dressement
productif de la région Auvergne nous
sommes évidemment attentifs à toutes ces
entreprises vous en avez cité un certain
nombre qui ne peuvent pas remonter au
ministère parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
trop le ministère se consacre au dossier
de plus de 400 salariés
entre les mains du Siri le Siri que
fait-il lorsqu'une entreprise donne des
signes de faiblesse il convoque tout le
tour de table les créanciers les
banquiers l'actionnaire les
organisations syndical sont associés les
élus de manière à trouver une solution
où on répartit l'effort et la ressource
et on sauve l'entreprise nous demandons
au commissairire de bressement productif
de faire exactement la même chose sur
leur territoire donc ils ont pour
mission d'abord de respecter la
confidentialité lorsque l'entreprise a
des difficultés en amont et de ne pas le
faire connaître c'est la raison pour
laquelle de nombreux élus ne peuvent pas
dans un premier temps être associé à la
connaissance des difficultés de
l'entreprise le SI si ces difficultés
apparaissent publiquement ù font l'objet
de rumeur les élus sont évidemment
conviés à être associés pour aider
l'entreprise à se redresser mais là
encore les efforts collectifs les
collectivités locales l'état organise
avec la médiation du crédit la médiation
de la sous-traitance la Banque de France
le tour de table qui permet de répartir
la ressource qui financera la
restructuration il arrive qu'il y ait
euh des emplois qui soient perdus à ce
moment-là donc cette discussion a lieu
avec les organisations syndicales et en
présence des élus les élus sont associés
à ces processus enfin si l'entreprise
est devant le tribunal de commerce
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est déjà dans le
processus de redressement vous savez et
vous l'avez mesuré vous-même dans
l'expérience de terrain que vous avez
que les entreprises qui sont devant les
tribunaux de commerce ont 75 % de chance
d'être en liquidation donc nous
préférons éviter le tribunal de commerce
préférons faire les choses avant dans la
protection des intérêts de l'entreprise
et de sa réputation c'est pourquoi les
commissaires dressement productif ont
beaucoup de travail il s'occupe des 3
millions et demi d'entreprises de moins
de 400 salariés et au Syrie on s'occupe
des 3500 entreprises de plus de 400
salariés voilà donc c'est une
déconcentration de l'action mais vous
êtes invité à évidemment participer à ce
travail c'est un travail de mobilisation
de toute la société euh monsieur euh euh
vergose parle de l'industrie maritime
évidemment en lien avec nos outres mèes
je lui répondrai déjà que monsieur Lurel
va me proposer pour les départements et
territoire d'outr m l'équivalent de
commissaire au redressement productif et
que la question de l'industrie maritime
est évidemment tout à fait fondamentale
dans ses filières dans ses lieux
d'investissement et que autant dans les
Antilles que dans l'océan Indien nous
sommes évidemment euh attaché à
euh développer toutes les potentialités
qui peuvent être utiles à nos
compatriotes quel que soit le lieu euh
où ils vivent euh monsieur Dubois évoque
la nécessité d'un Grenel des euh de
l'industrie ce Grenel existe et la
Conférence nationale de l'industrie que
le premier ministre vient de euh
amplifier sous forme de conseil national
l'industrie c'estàd qu'il va conseiller
le gouvernement
dans C ce
lieu nous y associons désormais les
régions les partenaires sociaux et il
est structuré selon les filières de
nouvelles filières d'ailleurs seront
invitées à se créer et à faire des
propositions et qui seront dans le débat
public soit les règlementaires soit
législatif soit dans le débat des
pratiques politiques gouvernementales
donc ce lieu existe et il est amené à
s'implifier vous posez la question de la
TVA sociale TVA sociale a fait l'objet
euh d'une décision politique
euh nous n'en sommes pas aux solutions
nous en sommes maintenant aux diagnostic
le
diagnostic il faudra qu'on ait cette
discussion il faudra d'ailleurs
l'équilibrer j'en ai dit un mot tout à
l'heure ensuite avant de passer aux
solutions et dans les solutions ben
chacun apportera sa contribution ou la
pierre au débat public vous indiquez
quelle est la position du Gouvernement
sur le gaz de schiste il y aura un débat
sur les énergie
euh et qui impliquera la Nation toute
entière à la rentrée donc nous aurons
l'occasion je crois que les
parlementaires et les deux chambres
seront associés à ce débat l'occasion
d'exprimer les positions des uns et des
autres sur le gaz de
schiste monsieur Jacquy pierre évoque
les problèmes de la sous-traitance dans
la vallée de la Haute Moselle et
notamment TRW j'ai répondu à Monsieur
Francis von tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée
nationale qui me questionnait aux
questions au gouvernement
que nous souaitions entrer en contact
avec les propriétaires du groupe
américain TRW afin de trouver les
conditions d'une
poursuite de enfin d'une
industrialisation prolongée du site avec
eux ou sans eux monsieur vugrenard
m'interroge sur les constructions
navales et notamment les projets de la
SNCM nous sommes parfaitement
sensibilisé à ce dossier qui suit son
cours je n'en dirai pas davantage
publiquement vous m'interrogez sur les
règles de concentration de la BPI nous
souhaitons mettre sur les territoires
des possibilités de décision et
d'engagement donc un haut niveau de
déconcentration associé à des
institutions décentralisées enfin
Monsieur Claude dylin évoque Henet et
son et son avenir je crois que nous
souhaitons quoi qu'il arrive et c'est
l'engagement de Peugeot
maintenir la le caractère et activité
industrielle dans ce site tout est à
imaginer mais pour l'instant nous n'en
sommes comme je le disais à vos
collègues tout à l'heure de scè
Saint-Denis nous n'en sommes pas là
monsieur retaillot a posé le problème du
prix plus élevé pour les consommateurs
aucune décision n'est prise nous
consultons les associations de
consommateurs nous réfléchissons avec
les opérateurs nous sommes d'abord dans
l'urgence demander le retrait des plans
sociaux aux deux grands opérateurs SFR
etbouill et ensuite nous cherch on à
faire évoluer l'équilibre du modèle
économique qui a été constitué dans les
dernières années qui a été fortement
impacté déstabilisé par l'arrivée de fre
qui a inventé un nouveau segment de
marché de nouvelles pratiques sociétales
avec le téléphone et donc un nouveau
modèle économique à nous de le régler il
est inacceptable que dans un secteur où
il n'y a pas de concurrence mondiale
c'est un secteur qui est protégé qui
utilise comme fond de commerce un bien
public qui s' appelle le domaine public
hertien dont les règles du jeu ne
dépendent que des pouvoirs publics c'est
le
réglage de l'arcepepe et du gouvernement
he accessoirement l'Union européenne
mais enfin ça reste quand même plutôt du
ressort du gouvernement que nous ayons
des plans sociaux dans ce secteur c'est
à nous de trouver l'équilibre et de le
régler au mieux de l'intérêt national et
de l'emploi monsieur le Président je
suis désolé de pas avoir pu entrer
davantage dans le détail sur les
questions importantes m'avez posé mais
je pense l'intuition que nous allons
nous
revoir
non c'est même pas une intuition c'est
une certitude une probabilité très forte
vous ne m'avez toujours pas donné la
date de calendrier sur le projet plôt
sera le mieux monsieur le Président ah
oui
d'accord bien mes chers collègues je
pense qu'on peut remercier le ministre
deavoir répondu avec autant de patience
à autant de questions vous voyez qu'on
peut arriver en respectant une règle de
2 3 minutes même si certaines débordent
je pense à Valérie
forcément j'ai dit Valérie pourquoi
tu il y en a qui se sent visé mais alors
et je pense que ça permet à plus de
collègu de d'arriver à poser leurs
questions c'est peut-être frustrant pour
certains et ceci ça permet en tous les
cas une expression très diverse je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre et soyez
sû